I want to give a shout out to our good
friend over from Eve 6 because he had
one of the best Tweets I've ever read
Elon Musk said you know Twitter is being
fair when extremists on the far right
and far left are simultaneously upset
Twitter aims to serve Center 80 of
people who wish to learn laugh and
engage in reasonable reason debate I
mean that's basically where we are and
the question here was that Elon bandier
over this symbol that appears to be a
swastika within the Star of David
calling it incitement to violence okay I
don't see how that's incitement I think
it's offensive but shout out to our good
friend uh Max over at Eve 6 who tweeted
people on the right are holding you to
your free speech absolutist position
which is ABS which is obviously turned
out to be fake and people on the left
are mad at you because you're a union
busting billionaire Centrist
which is the most annoying kind of right
winger
you can tell he's a poet but um
that right there is example exemplifying
everything the enlightened Centrist
people have been saying it's like dude
most of the people who are like Center
left or whatever have said this yeah
there's some views I have that are
probably a little left leaning and some
that are a little right laning and then
the left Emily says right Wingers and
you're like okay I guess he just said it
right there okay there you go a Centrist
is a right winger that's what he said
well it's because they don't like when
we think about the political Spectrum we
often think about this line you know if
you believe this you're more to the left
or you're drift more this way or right
and they don't look at it that way
because this is not political for them
this is religious for them it is a
religion and and if you're uh if you're
let's say you're a devout Christian are
you allowed to just hey you know what
those Ten Commandments love them a lot
number Eight's gonna have to go though
that's not gonna work for me no
immediately that is well no that's wrong
what do you what are you you're standing
against our religion what are you
talking about that's part of the
religion that's why they're so strict
with their people because it's not a
political ideology they worship it it
very much is a political a religion for
these people think about this there was
a great point I read on Twitter I can't
remember who said it when when Roe v
Wade gets overturned and the Republicans
immediately start scrubbing abortion
pro-life issues from their websites the
question arises do you actually believe
in being pro-life because if you're
gonna hide and not show anybody that it
was clearly never an issue you actually
cared about you don't actually believe
these things well
some of these religions I think deserve
Reformation like some of them were built
a couple thousand years ago when it was
okay to beat women or it was okay like
pork was dangerous to eat because you
might get trichinosis from Dirty blood
like now we have good sanitation so like
uh decadence for instance in Islam it's
looked way down upon in on it in its own
but the reality is it's okay to be
decadent if you're charitable like have
a beautiful life have wonderful things
if you're willing to be charitable with
your funds I think Islam could benefit I
think a lot of Muslims would love to not
feel guilt about living in luxury
because it's a natural part of affluence
and that comes with you know the beauty
of God I don't want to I'm not trying to
be menian but I I think we're not having
the same conversation we might be having
a similar well you were saying how left
this so you're treating this like a
religion and saying just because you
take out the eighth uh of the Ten
Commandments I think sometimes it's okay
for religions to ebb and flow and change
with the times yeah but they they're not
interested in that the the what I'm
trying to classify what we're up against
they're not interested in changing with
the times now now the only thing they
will change is they appeal to they have
to find different malcontents this is
what people don't understand about
communism and why people oh you're crazy
they're not Communists right one most of
the prominent people in the Democrat
Party openly call themselves socialists
now anyway I don't know why people think
I'm nuts for saying that two communism
is not some workers thing communism in
the Soviet Union looked drastically
different than it did in China why
because you had different mouth contents
and the Soviet Union you had the urban
poor so they appealed to the urban poor
so when you had the Soviet Communists
trying to put it in China they were
yelling at people like Mao saying focus
on the urban poor and Mao said you're a
freaking idiot we don't have
malcontented Urban poor we have
malcontended rural poor here we have to
change it there that it looked different
in Cambodia in America it looks
radically different there because we
didn't have those Urban poor or rural
poor do we had different malcontents
here that's why they focused on the
feminists that's why they focused on the
climate change and others the lgbtq Air
Force guys that's why they get
infiltrated the Civil Rights Movement
you have to find society's mouth
contents because Society is a rock and
when you find the mouth contents what
you're doing is you're finding the
cracks in the Rock you're feeling it and
freezing it that's what communism divide
and conquer that's exactly and that's
exactly what they're doing that's why
the family unit is one of the key uh
things that they're trying to destroy
that they're trying to prevent people
from having because if they have a
strong family unit they won't be able to
worship the state and personally if you
believe in a parks department I believe
you're a communist it doesn't take much
for me uh I think all of the people out
there there's a lot of Communists out
there because they believe in the common
good and and a lot of this is just
lunacy I I mean this hey hey I got to
speak my truths here I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna be censoring myself here uh
you commies
particular States Department
yeah you know if you actually look at
what the political spectrum is I would
probably be described as tradition
additional liberal or social liberal
Luke Anarchist probably yeah but in the
modern iteration of what these words
mean it's just like they don't mean
anything like liberal is used to
referred to anyone on the left far right
is anybody who's Centrist to far right
yeah it's just I don't even it's all
it's all nonsense we're kind of
Uncharted Territory like what do you do
in that situation just kind of have
shows like this and keep reminding
people what you think the definition is
and hope that they more people believe
you than Merriam-Webster when they
switch the definition of the word
feminist like they've been doing that
yeah that's what the websites have been
doing the dictionary websites have been
changing definitions in real time and uh
the definition of woman I remember we
covered this became circular because it
was like a person who identifies as a
woman was the definition of woman and
it's like how do you use the word in its
own definition what does this mean yeah
look to answer your question there is no
when you're on when you're constantly
seeking out society's malcontents every
society as I talked about is going to
have different ones so the BET look the
best guard against that is to not have
many mouth contents to run your ship the
right way there's a reason the
Communists were able to infiltrate the
civil rights movement because we had a
bunch of black people who were getting
crept on in this country and they were
looking for some kind of solution to
that so that was an obvious one you
would go to feminists are mad about
everything all the time because they're
horrible so that was an obvious one too
it just you're always going to have new
mouth contents and that's you're always
going to have powerful people who find
them and tell those malcontents give me
power and I'll hurt the people you blame
for your problems I would go even
further than that and I think with a lot
of powerful people understanding that
kind of dichotomy that you just broke
down very eloquently that they are
creating unhappy people and there's a
big agenda to make people even unhappier
than they are right now and I do believe
people are being made unhealthy people
are being made sad people are made uh to
feel like they have empty lives
predominantly because people understand
on a bigger level when they don't have a
religion when they don't have a family
when they're not healthy when they don't
have a life that is worth living they're
going to give everything to Central
controllers to to trinkets made from
China to government authorities that
don't give a damn about them and they
will be owned and and operated by the
state essentially well bitterness always
always brings out more bitterness right
bitterness never solves anything the one
feminist if she's miserable at 20 and
bitter she's going to be 10 times as
miserable with her 15 cats at 40 and
weigh another 50 pounds and then I'll
get worse and worse and worse I'm not
even trying to and that was the bigger
that was the biggest Democratic voter
base this election is like in the
midterm know ladies who are single right
single single women that's what I said
yeah
it is true it's it's bitterness begets
more bitter bitterness and you see
people you'll see people say crazy
things all the time now uh LeBron James
is actually a great example LeBron James
is the American success story Horrible
no dad rough upbringing and yet now he's
a billionaire one of the great NBA
players at all time a testament to to
hard work and perseverance and man
that's the American story and LeBron
James is a miserable suck and all he
does is whine about this place all the
time and when we look at it we think
that's crazy what what's wrong with you
bitter bitter bitter bitter bitter now
he's got a billion dollars right now
he's sipping on booze better than this
on a private plane somewhere eating
caviar thinking about how much his life
sucks think about what Elon Musk is
representing with the Twitter takeover
and his series of tweets he's posting
memes he's laughing it's a joke we're
all on Twitter we're all laughing a big
component of whatever modern left versus
right is a bunch of people with sticks
jammed square right in their rectums and
a bunch of people who just even the
craziest things are funny because what
can you do but laugh I mean that's the
clown World meme it's the Joker meme
it's like
you know watching everything to send
into chaos we know it's bad but all you
can do is laugh and go along for the
ride versus the other people who no
matter how good it gets they're
screaming about how awful it is it's
really insightful what you said about
getting people out of the gutter
mentally like giving people hope making
them so they're not malcontent they're
not miserable maybe making people
content bringing people some sort of at
least belief that things will get better
and Luke talked about this like what
brings contentment we saw in this
country and I'm not downplaying
medication at all I understand
medication has helped a lot of lives
save a lot of lives change a lot of
lives but I saw a stat recently about
the number of Americans who were on
psychological psychological meds and I'm
not even downplaying that sometimes
that's necessary the number was
staggering it was something it was
something like 79 million why do we have
79 million people in need why aren't we
looking at a way to get 79 million
people off of that but instead we don't
because we become a pill Mill Country
for a lot of different reasons we don't
we're not out there look when covet hit
I don't care what you believe about
covet what you believe about vaccines
none of that stuff matters to me at all
everyone with a half a brain knew if you
weren't fat you had a better chance of
not getting coveted not having severe
complication from covid and we knew very
early on that vitamin D was very healthy
for you not one person and government
not one public health expert said hey
whatever else you do go for a walk in
the Sun for 20 minutes once yes that's
what I say just one time but then then
shut the hell about it but but he should
have been screaming about it and
preaching about it for a very long time
but we do have a very medicated country
that disassociates itself from reality
people are so depressed people are so
sad and and I would make an argument and
again I'm not a scientist and a doctor
but I would say people need to feel that
so they would change their reality but
to keep the Cog in the wheel to keep the
rat on the on the wheel you have to
medicate them so they don't realize the
true consequences of their actions and
how their life is just being sucked out
of them by the corporate multinational
State thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time